Hey there friends. So few weeks ago I
got a message from a Patreon supporter
that has kind of stuck in my head and
not wormed its way out since I first
read it. This Patreon supporter was
asking me what I think is a very
insightful question which is how is it
that I am so free with my expression
because this person in particular it
feels very self-conscious a lot of the
time. And I think there's really two
questions to break out of this. One is
how to feel less self-conscious and the
other one is how to really engage in
more free expression. So I'm going to
tackle these questions in two different
videos here. Starting with this one on
how to become less
self-conscious. Drex here from Drex
Factor PO sharing with you the love of
PO spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain. And today I'm going
to share with you my best tips for
becoming less self-conscious. But before
we dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b businessiness friend
of the channel, Becca Beckonin. Thank
you so much for supporting my channel,
my work, and my mission. So, I will say
from the jump that I feel incredibly
illquipped to answer this question.
Namely because I don't spend a lot of
time thinking about how to become less
self-conscious. In fact, I feel
self-conscious a lot of the time. I'm
currently walking around my neighborhood
talking to a little vlogging camera and
I feel tremendously self-conscious about
it. And yet, I'm doing it anyhow. And I
I think there's some core piece to
uncover there about, you know, that that
old quote of courage is not the absence
of fear, but it's what you do despite
the fear. But as I'm thinking about it,
I'm recognizing that there are some
things that have changed for me over the
years in terms of how I kind of inhabit
my self-consciousness and how I respond
to it. And I think it does have to be
said from the jump that the biggest
variable that made a difference for me
here is that I have been going to
therapy for years now and the help has
helped as they say on the West Wing. I
think that that is probably the single
most important intervention I've made in
my adult life um on a lot of different
levels and for a lot of different
things. And at the end of this video, I
will circle back around and give you
some uh options for how you might seek
that kind of therapeutic intervention
yourselves. But in kind of rolling this
question around in my head, I did
realize that there were a few exercises
that I either came up with on my own or
that uh came up in those therapy
sessions that did help out quite a lot.
So, I'm going to try and share those
with you. So, I do think that the core
of what's going on when we're
self-conscious is that we are kind of
basing our opinions on ourselves around
how the people around us respond to us.
So, we may be in a place where we feel a
little like, oh, you know, I have this
flaw and that flaw and worried that
other people are going to see them or
that they're going to see a completely
different flaw that we're not aware of.
And in all of those different cases,
what that really comes down to is having
a sense of self where you're kind of
looking for the reactions of other
people to know how to feel about
yourself. And I think that there are
some interventions that can
help move that I guess dial around to a
place where you're able to give yourself
the feeling of validation that you need
to walk into a place with your hel head
held high. So, exercise number one, and
this is one that I kind of found on my
own, but that uh therapy really helped
me explore in more detail, is to, as
corny as it sounds, create a list of
things that you like about
yourself. Could be small things, it
could be big
things. Maybe it's how kind you are to
other people. Maybe it's how curious you
are. Maybe it is just the fact that
you're a friendly person and you want
everybody to feel comfortable. The point
is you want to make a list of things
that you treasure about yourself that
you love about yourself. And these are
things that nobody can touch. These are
things that regardless of what anybody
around you is saying or thinking about
you that you know you are showing up to
the party bringing something that you
think is important and that that is
immovable. I've done this exercise
several times over the years and I got
to tell you every time I sit down and do
it I wind up in tears by the end of it
because part of what's happening there
is I'm reminding myself you know what
I'm not such a bad guy. I've got a lot
going for me. And more to the point,
there's quite a lot about me that I love
and I going through this exercise I
think is a great way to reconnect with
those things. Okay, so item number two
is a little bit more of a challenge. Uh
but it's kind of the flip side to item
number one. Where item number one is
kind of coming to a place where we see,
accept, and love our strengths, we also
have to recognize that all of us are
human and therefore all of us have flaws
and that those flaws don't make us
unworthy. That that's just an aspect of
being human. And don't get me wrong,
sometimes we have a temper and that can
have a negative impact on the people
around us and that's probably a thing
that we want to work on.
But also
too, we can recognize that we are all
human and we all have our moments when
we're not our best. That doesn't make us
unworthy. It just makes us human. And
you can take those moments and either
look at them as a moment where you have
something to learn and take forward with
you or you kind of internalize and hold
on to those things and say, "This makes
me a bad person. This makes me
unworthy." And the challenge here is to
let go of those moments to be like, you
know, yeah, I could have handled that
better. And I'm going to take that and
I'm going to learn from it, but I'm not
going to judge myself as a result of it.
I am going to learn to love my flaws as
much as I love my strengths and
recognize that they just make me human
in the end and change what I need to in
order to improve both my life and the
lives of those around me. A big part of
this is simply holding grace for
yourself and grace for others. You can
have a day when you don't react to
something as you'd like to and sit and
think on and be like, well, you know,
I'm under a lot of stress and, you know,
my car broke down and I I'm really
worried I might lose my job, so on and
so forth. And so I reacted to something
in a way that I kind of regret. And it's
okay to say, you know what? Yeah, I
could have handled that better.
and engage in accountability. If you
snapped at somebody, you can say, you
know, hey, I'm sorry you didn't deserve
that. Or if you don't have that
opportunity, you can simply say, you
know what? Yeah, I didn't do this so
well, but I can let go of it. I can get
on with my day and recognize that I
should maybe give myself a little bit of
slack and as much as possible try to
avoid additional stressors. See how that
works. All right. So, so far we have
been doing a lot of internal work and
now it is time to start putting in some
of the external work too. There's a
statement that I have been kind of
holding on to as a mantra and repeatedly
telling myself at different points in
the past few months and uh sometimes in
really specific situations and I want
you to internalize it too and it's this.
Other people's opinions do not determine
my value. If somebody's angry at me,
that does not make me a bad person. That
does not make me unworthy of their love
or anybody
else's. I am still worthy and nothing
can change that. And like this is really
hard cuz you can tell yourself that, but
actually feeling it, internalizing it,
that can take a little bit of work. But
it is worthwhile because when you can do
this, all of a sudden it means you start
letting go of all the guilt and shame
that you're carrying around with you
when you do have other people's opinions
piling up on you. It's really funny
because I get a lot, and I do mean a
lot, of uh pretty negative comments on
some of my content. And in a lot of
cases, my first reaction is to feel an
enormous amount of shame when those
comments come in. And it's funny cuz
like a week or two later, maybe I'll run
back across those comments and I'll
think about where I was in my head when
I originally read them or god forbid
when I was responding to them and I'll
be able to look back and say, you know,
that kind of wasn't that big a deal.
This person was just approaching this
from their own angle with whatever stuff
they have, from their own background,
from their own
story. Ultimately, this wasn't about me.
This was about them and them projecting
whatever they have going on into my
video or into this conversation. That
says nothing about me. That says
something about them.
And so what I've been trying to do is
when those moments pop up now to try and
think in advance and be like, okay, so
let's not think about how I'm feeling
right now. Let's think about how I'm
going to be feeling 2 weeks from now.
Let's imagine that I'm reading this
comment then. How much do I feel like
this actually impacts my world? And
almost always the answer to that is not
a whole lot. So item number four on this
list is going to be strangely enough to
acknowledge your discomfort. That is if
you are in a situation where you feel
uncomfortable to sit with that feeling
to acknowledge that you are feeling it.
Not to try to numb it away or escape
from it in some way, shape or form, but
to look at it as a teacher. Your body
and brain are trying to tell you
something in this moment to accept that
discomfort rather than thinking that it
must be eliminated because it's trying
to tell you something. It's actually
remarkably powerful to be in a moment
where you can tell yourself, I'm a human
being and I am having a feeling and be
able to say, yes, you know what?
Something is making me uncomfortable
right now. Let's figure out what that
is. Is the music too loud here? Uh, am I
feeling hungry? Is my outfit
uncomfortable? Do I need to do something
to change this and feel more at ease? Or
is this just simply not my scene? Maybe,
you know, I kind of miscalculated and I
need some time to myself this evening
or, you know, maybe I'm really, really,
really stressed out about my car being
towed while I'm at this park. Are there
ways that we can fix these problems? And
also too, let's acknowledge the fact
that that discomfort is happening in the
first place and feel comfortable kind of
validating it for ourselves, you know.
And item number five, the last one on
this list is kind of closely tied to
item number four, and that is to listen
to your body and your brain and the
messages that they are sending
you. Part of this just goes into
self-love of saying, you know, hey, my
feelings are real. My feelings are
valid. My body and brain both need
things and those are things that will
make me happier and healthier in the
long run and I should probably listen to
them. Like say I've had a stressful
week. Maybe it's a good idea for me to
go out and get a hike done even if I do
have to shoot a video. Really what I'm
getting at with this one is I think it's
really common for us to listen to other
people's kind of body language and the
tone of their voice more than we
sometimes listen to ourselves. More than
we sometimes listen to that tight
feeling in our shoulders or you know
that alarm bell going off in our brain
telling us oh no I'm not sure if you
know this is the right crowd for me to
hang out with right now. And I think
it's important that we learn to listen
to what our bodies and brains are
telling us first and what the people
around us are telling us second. And
it's only after we're in a place, I
think, where we can acknowledge those
feelings within ourselves that it
becomes easier to be there for other
people as well because their feelings
are also real. But if we're not
acknowledging our own feelings at the
same time, it can be really, really
difficult not to see those feelings as
being in competition. So learn to listen
to yourself and more important than
anything else, recognize that your
internal voice is just as important as
those voices that are outside of you,
too. So, I hope these tips are helpful,
and I hope they at least get you started
on a journey of working with your
feelings of self-consciousness.
It is still very much a work that is in
progress for me and accept that it's
probably going to be a long journey for
you too and it's really kind of a
process rather than something that has
an end point at any point in the future.
Um once again I will highly recommend
that this is where you start and not
where you end on the process. I really,
really, really think that the best
option here is to kind of talk to a
therapist and figure out your specific
variables and how you navigate feelings
of self-consciousness. Um, I found my
therapist on the Open Path Collective,
that is uh
openathcollective.org. They do uh
discounted uh therapy sessions for
people who are lowinccome. I will
include a link to that website down in
the description. Um, I highly recommend
checking them out. Thanks once again to
the Patreon supporter that sent me that
message and got my gears turning on how
exactly I could help them out as well as
I'm sure a lot of other people out there
as well who are struggling with the very
same issues. Did you get anything out of
this video? Please make sure to like,
share, comment, and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not exist were it not for
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my Flo patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. And if you would like to support
my work, you got a couple options of how
you could do that. Number one, if you'd
like to get your name in the credits or
access to a whole host of other rewards,
you can go sign up for my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. I'll include a
link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Um, also too,
if you would prefer not to sign up for
another subscription service, I can't
blame you. You can send me a one-off
donation via either Venmo or PayPal. I
am at Drexfactor on both platforms. I
will leave link to both links to both of
those things down in the description as
well. And if you'd like to see some of
my other videos talking about mental
health, uh I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those videos once
again down in the description as well as
up on screen. Thanks so much for going
for a walk with me. And I hope you get
out and do some flowing today cuz it's
not just good for your body, it is also
good for your brain. Take care now and
I'll see you in a new video real soon.
Peace.